well there's a case which I discuss in
the book a very important that I think
an interesting case of an honor killing
in Pakistan and it's important because
it draws attention to the fact that this
is not a practice only engaged in by
candle rural peasants the woman in the
case that i discussed who was killed by
her family by somebody for her family
was a law student her mother was a
gynecologist her father was the most it
was the head of the business Better
Business Bureau as it were in his
hometown her husband was an from whom
she was trying to who she was trying to
divorce which is why she was killed was
it was an MD they were very they were
successful modern highly educated
Pakistanis she was killed in the office
of her lawyer because her mother came
with this man and and he took out a gun
and shot her in front of the lawyer now
that makes it clear that in that context
that this was you know decade ago it
makes it clear that in that context
these people these respectable people
just didn't think it was dishonorable to
murder your daughter in front of your
lawyer I right front of her lawyer the
practice that she was the lawyer was in
was a very distinguished practice in
Pakistan headed by two sister women
lawyers one of whom was the head of the
the national human rights organization
and she said immediately upon this
exactly the right thing her name is Asma
Jahangir she said what kind of honor is
it to kill an unarmed woman right she
didn't say who cares about honor she got
the point that which I don't think would
work I don't think in a society that's
full of people who care about honor or
hire out as they call it that we could
that we could hope for any significant
change by just attacking on her head on
where she said was and that's a good
question I mean how is it that a man who
organizes the murder of his own daughter
gets to be entitled to respect well
that's
complicated thing about the way things
work over in that particular honor
system an honor system by the way that
was quite common around the world you
could find it in Italy 100 years ago
that's very much the same thing that
honor system needs shifting in the first
you know if you're going to shift it you
have first to insist on the wrongness of
what it requires but that's not hard to
do murder is already illegal the Koran
prohibits it already xand Pakistan is a
Muslim state and so there are lots of
reasons or you can give why you
shouldn't do it but you also have to
shift the the honor system and that's
what they're doing by banging on the
point the correct point that it just
doesn't make sense to think of it as
honorable for a man to kill an unarmed
woman and there's a nice there's a
website organized by some it's called
Arabs and Muslims against Allah killing
and and at that website their slogan is
no honor and honor killing and I think
that's absolutely right so what's going
on already is that is a shift there are
already people who see this so ready
people who say honor requires us not to
murder these women and I think as as the
dialogue goes on and provided it's
conducted respectfully across societies
and within that society where there are
many people who agree with you and me
about the wrongness of honor killing as
that dialogue ozone will be the shift
and as more and more people come to
identify this activity not with honor
but this honor as in China with
foot-binding there'll be a moment a kind
of tipping point when it goes from being
something you do in order to defend your
honor to something which if you do it
brings you shame and that's I you know
I'm famously in all my work more
optimistic than many people i'm a bit of
a Pollyanna but i think that that's
what's happening already i think there's
a shift going on i think they're making
the right arguments that it's wrong it's
illegal it's on muslim and that is
dishonorable